القصف الروسي مستمر على شرق اوكرانيا ساحه
الحرب الاطول منذ بدايه الخسوه هذا المنزل
دمر بالكامل بعدما استهدف صاروخ روسي قريه
ماكسيم اليانفكا في منطقه
سكانه من دون ماوى
هناك حفره كبيره في الارض عندما خرجت من
المنزل لاتفقد الوضع سقط حطاما فوقي ثم
سمعت زوجه تصرخ وجدتها جريحه تحت الانقاظ
موسكو التي تكثف هجماتها لاحكام السيطره
على اقليم اي دونتس كوالوجانسك اعلنت انها
حققت خطوات اضافيه في طريقها نحو مدينه
بخموت التي تعتبرها نقطه انطلاق رئيسيه
للاستيلاء على بلدات اخرى في الغرب من
منطقه
تقدم ينفيه الرئيس الاوكراني ويؤكد ان
قواته تصدت للهجوم وتحافظ على موقعها عند
الخطوط الاماميه
من المهم للغايه انه على الرغم من الضغط
الكبير على قواتنا لم يطرا اي تغيير على
الخطوط الاماميه
المعارك زادت حدتها في بلدتي افديفكا
واوبلست في منطقه دانيت
حسب هجوم العدو هنا مثلا العدو نشط للغايه
لكن الوضع تحت السيطره ولدينا عيون في
السماوات وراقب الوضع عندما نتلقى امرا
باطلاق النار ننفذه فورا لنصيب الهدف
كياذا تؤكد ان القوات الروسيه كبدت خسائر
كبيره بينما يعلن الكرملين انه يحقق مزيدا
من التقدم